we did it
[Music]
in a world where burgers reign supreme
three amigos set out to clone the most
iconic fast food burgers of all time
the burger illuminati is back at it
again and this time we're paying tribute
to three
burger titans the mcdonald's big mac the
white castle
slider and the in-and-out double-double
animal style
they've all changed the burger landscape
forever we've got some tricks up our
sleeves
and some history to uncover y'all ready
for this
the crew is back kenji you look like
you're recording a podcast
george you're back at the burger museum
how's it been
it's been great can't complain been good
have you been oh man you know just busy
smashing burgers
getting my reps in i actually broke a
spatula yesterday you need spatula
just saying that was a tea up for you
buddy that was
the tea up for you today we're talking
about
the most iconic fast food burgers the
white castle slider
the in-n-out double-double animal style
the big mac these are burgers
that were icons of the burger business
and these three virtually
changed the industry as we know it today
why do we appreciate the fast food
burgers so much was just so ingrained
into our culture as americans and as
burger lovers
when i think of fast food like it's
actually like usually fond childhood
memories that it brings back it's not
about the best burger
it's a burger plus a memory nostalgia is
part of the flavor profile
that's a very important thing and it's
also consistency so if you take
nostalgia and consistency and put them
together you have the reason that people
go
and visit fast food restaurants all the
time so alvin
you're doing the big mac now to get the
big mac right you have to
put the club in the middle right which
is that middle
piece of bread right yeah we're not half
fasting this at all i
like requested to have this burger bun
made so it's got like a
sesame seeds on them you know recreating
fast food at home it's like you're on
like a treasure hunt you know it's like
you're trying to figure out
unlock the secret i'm doing a double
double um animal style with uh
chopped chilies and whole grilled onion
which is the way i typically order vine
i've really been to a white castle in a
while i'd say right now this is not an
easy
burger to recreate oh yeah it is
unquestionably an engineering feat but
they figured out and how hardcore are
you going are you doing like the little
the five little holes in the patties and
everything oh yeah
well it sounds like we're all taking
this very seriously
and i'm watching you kenji because the
double double animal style that's like
one of my favorite burgers in the whole
world
i can't wait to see what we all come up
with let's get it
you've heard me talk ad nauseum about
the birth of the american hamburger
and also the birth of white castle but
wait until you see what happens
next so here we go again
imagine it's the 1940s and you just
stepped into white castle
this is exactly what they'd be wearing
ruby how do i look at this uniform
um slightly idiot slightly idiotic
no the answer is authentic i look
authentic
authentically idiotic authentically
idiotic thank you very much thank you
very little
looking clean was part of the game and
white castle was
winning it if you took a job at white
castle they handed you
a pamphlet with a diagram inside of what
you needed to look like when you were
working
let's see if i had passed the test be
ready to make suggestions
no you can't have a veggie burger sorry
get rid of chewing gum
button all shirt buttons oops
check no body odor
cap should cover hair it's not bad
the paper cap of a white catholic
uniform is important because guess what
white castle invented the paper cap
don't forget that these guys
precede all the mcdonald's and the
wendy's and the burger kings and
everybody else
they truly are the world's first
fast-food hamburger restaurant
but didn't come without growing paints
ready for a little bit of a history
lesson
as white castle was riding high on a
wave of success the country faced two
massive setbacks
the great depression in the 30s and
world war ii in the 40s
if they wanted to survive they had to
innovate when government mandated beef
rationing in 1943
white castle became the first burger
chain to stockpile meat
to avoid supply shortages and to make up
for lost revenue on meatless days
they also became the first burger chain
to start selling french fries
after the war they thought they were in
the clear yet beef prices continued to
skyrocket
at this point white castle created
something that still exists today
the holy hamburger in 1947 one ounce
patties shrank to eight tenths of an
ounce
effectively getting two additional
patties from every pound of beef
the solution was to poke holes in the
patty according to white castle this
allowed beef to cook more quickly
and the bun to become steamy soft but
allegedly it was also an ingenious way
to be frugal
as always white castle was at the
forefront of hamburger innovation
you ready to make a white castle slider
a real white castle slider
let's do this it's not just the uniform
i did a lot of work
to get this right it's an engineering
project
not so much a recipe it's all about
method notice the tank
that's because this is the tank from the
last episode we talked about the dawn of
the burger
well white castle actually still today
uses a tank
you ever notice everything at white
castle square there's a reason for that
they invented the first fast food
hamburger model and they did that by
standardizing the size of the bun
buns were made in sheep hands and they
were square
another wartime rationing victim was
fresh onions they would rehydrate
dehydrated onions in
water and throw this onto the flat top
the 1940s a white castle operator in new
york city devised the method
which became known as the new york style
of steaming patties on a bed of onions
it sped things up made things faster
and then another operator in ohio
figured out if you poke
holes in the burger would actually help
to steam the burger and a whole new
method was born
you can use a straw i used a hollowed
out ballpoint pen
seems to work just fine five holes
[Music]
there okay we're done
castle takes the patties and they put
them onto
this bed of onions they take the buns
they
heal the butt they put that down on top
of the raw patty which i think is very
strange but
trust me this works and we're causing
lots of smoke here i think
whoops that's what's happening right now
is this environment
of onions and beef grease and water
that is steaming the buns steaming the
burger patties
hey that smells pretty authentic by the
way this is like 2 a.m in my hometown
growing up right here and one thing i've
learned about white castle of sliders is
that they don't get flipped
they cook in place these are ready to go
wow just like in white castle they cook
like that like nothing
comes off like that see that the bun
goes underneath pinched ah yeah
yeah it's hot yay high faster than that
see pinch and pull
it's a pension pull look at that a very
tiny piece of american cheese on top
mustard under oop mustard underneath
sorry i made a mess and then a pickle oh
[ __ ]
[ __ ] uh
keep rolling oh [ __ ] oh no my uniform's
not clean anymore
everything's falling apart
[Music]
wardrobe oh that's my face
[Music]
so steamy soft it's a white castle
slider
it's perfect it's an absolute perfect
clone of white castle slider
oh my god
we did it we [ __ ] did it
that is so [ __ ] good
that is so good if you were a customer
in the 1940s at white castle and you
wanted a slider
that's exactly what you'd get one of the
most important hamburgers
in hamburger history take it away alvin
ladies and gentlemen y'all know what
time it is
wait is that trademarked
[Laughter]
today we're cloning one of the most
iconic fast food burgers
the big mac according to wikipedia in
2007
a mcdonald's spokesperson said that the
united states alone sold
560 million big macs in a year
that's 17 big macs every second
34. 68 68 big macs
already don't ask me what's after 68.
it has this crazy bun like it's not just
a typical
bottom bun and top bun there's a club
level
you know me i love the club
hey
without further ado it'll be my pleasure
to show all of y'all
how i make the big mac let's flip some
patties
first thing we're going to do chiffonade
don't be scared it just means sliced
lettuce
super thin it creates a nest for the
patties to live on
so that it doesn't move around and pop
out of your burger so yeah they
definitely do this at mcdonald's
we'll set that aside let's make some
special sauce
the internet is wild about the big mac's
special sauce but one thing is for sure
there's no ketchup in this sauce so if
you're putting ketchup in your big mac
sauce
you're wrong friend after researching
after trying this 100 times this is the
big mac sauce
that i've come up with first things
first mayonnaise
all american yellow mustard we're
talking three parts mayo
one part mustard one part caramelized
onions
one part roasted garlic puree this is
just garlic cooked down in olive oil
one part relish sweet relish not dill
this is what gives it its legendary
color paprika
the sweet stuff if you put smoked
paprika
you [ __ ] it all up sugar and then
my favorite a tablespoon of pickle juice
give that a nice mix
that's it that's the one
i haven't failed you yet so trust me on
this all right
we got our diced onions shredded lettuce
our sauce
oh important you know i want that extra
mile
you got the perfect seated triple decker
burger bun the crown the heel and the
club so let's cut it up
and if you can't get this just get two
bottom buns mix it with the top one
you'll be fine you gotta butter your
buns
three minutes on each side
pro tip secret burger tip i have a
tortilla press the big mac patties are
like not even an
ounce put the patty in between the
parchment and just give it a nice press
voila we're gonna hit it with some salt
one side only these are super thin
pepper and then we'll fry these guys up
put the patty seasoned side down
a minute and a half two minutes on each
side and it'll cook all the way through
we're saucing the bottom bun don't get
rid
pickles for this it has to be smooth
pickles diced white onion on here
shredded lettuce these are ready to flip
oh
cold cheese on the bottom bun on top of
the lettuce
and you're like oh alvin i like melted
cheese better okay fine you want melted
cheese that's not how they do it at
mcdonald's but
you can pull a hot patty off of the
grill and throw it right
on top we'll top that patty with the
club level bun
hit it with more sauce white onion
another
wad of iceberg lettuce top patty put the
crown on to the big mac
and there you go the iconic mcdonald's
big mac
oh there you go the lettuce is dripping
so good i'm loving it
all right kenji you're up all right
thanks alvin so today i'm gonna be
cloning one of my favorite burgers it's
a
california icon this is the in and out
double double animal style with a whole
grilled onion plus chopped chilis which
is how i like to order it to me it's
sort of the platonic ideal of a fast
food
burger it's inexpensive it uses high
quality ingredients fresh
and it's really sort of about that
airplane it's one of those burgers it's
just really more than the sum of its
parts
which is what i love about it when you
order your burger animal style what they
do is they swap out that raw onion
for a pile of grilled caramelized onions
they also give you extra sauce
extra pickles and they fry the burger
patty directly in mustard on the griddle
in and out has this sort of cult like
appeal to it because of the secret menu
you can highly customize their burgers
depending on how you order them
you feel like you're coming up with like
a little conspiracy with the guy who's
taking your order
so the first thing we're going to do is
our bun so i'm going to start with a
little bit of butter
one of the sort of hallmarks of an
in-n-out bun is that it's really well
toasted so it's like actually
sort of crunchy when you bite into it
next we're gonna move on to the spread
which is the other essential part of
in-n-out flavor
there's no official recipe that you can
get anywhere but you can look up
the basic ingredients in their
nutritional information and then you can
also do a little bit of math
to sort of figure out what the ratio of
those ingredients are in and out spread
is essentially made from ketchup and
mayonnaise along with some pickle relish
and a little bit of extra sugar
uh and so the way i calculated this was
i found that on their nutrition info if
you substitute ketchup for
spread you save 80 calories per sandwich
and there's about two
tablespoons of spread per sandwich 15
calories from every
tablespoon of ketchup 80 calories from
every tablespoon of mayo
so 15 times the percentage of ketchup in
the ratio plus
80 times the percentage of mayo in the
ratio is equal to 55 total
calories which is what you get per
tablespoon of spread from there you can
do a little bit of math some
simultaneous equations
and you find that the percentage of
ketchup is 38
percentage of mayo is 62 in order to
figure out the amount of relish
i washed some of the in and out spread
through a fine mesh sieve to see how
much
actual pickle stuff was left in there
and so from there i got this very basic
ratio
of all the ingredients that go into the
spread
sometimes i'm okay just kind of winging
it and then sometimes i let the inner
nerd
get a hold of me and then i end up going
down these rabbit holes like this so
it's
two tablespoons plus two teaspoons of
mayo two tablespoons of ketchup
two teaspoons of pickle relish half
teaspoon each of white vinegar and
sugar and then you mix that together the
way i order it is
animal style with an added whole grilled
onion you get two types of onion on
there you get
chopped caramelized onions and then a
whole slice of onion like this
and they put it directly on the griddle
and they cook that next to your burger
you're also going to need a slice of
tomato your hand leaf lettuce
it's iceberg which is what you want
because it has that crunch it has that
kind of sweetness to it
and let's check on our buns yeah so you
want those really nice crunchy edges
so and in and out they would use
pre-pattied meat that's already sort of
round and spread out and they just go
straight onto the flat top i prefer to
do mine smash burger style and i really
want to spread them wide i want them to
be
slightly wider than the width of the bun
before i turn it i'm going to put
chopped chilies on one of these patties
these are just pickled banana peppers
you could use pickled cherry peppers
and in and out they use the little
packets of sport peppers right when i'm
ready to flip
just some yellow mustard and that's
going to kind of cook into the burger
on the second side when i flip it and
that mustard
browning and sort of that vinegar in the
mustard concentrating that's what sort
of gives it that extra flavor boost
right at the end
so i got my toasted bun sauce is going
in the very bottom
a bunch of pickles are going on there
iceberg
that crunch slice of tomato i always
like to season my tomato
and let's get our cheese on our burgers
and on top of one of these
caramelized onions
whole grilled onion all right
first thing you notice with this burger
is actually texture the crunch from the
well-toasted bun
and then there's all that crunchy
iceberg in there and all the pickles as
well and then you've got the
relish and the spread and you've got the
chopped chilies on the burger itself so
it's got a lot of that sort of
concentrated vinaigrette flavor and then
of course sort of balanced out by all
the sweetness of the caramelized onions
and the whole grilled onion
i hope i made all of them proud while i
have your attention i thought i'd give a
quick shout out to
um no kid hungry it's a non-profit that
i've been working with especially now
there are so many
kids who are food insecure don't know
where their next meal is going to come
from
and with parents a lot of parents out of
work that problem has compounded
in the last year so head down to the
description below and there'll be a link
to my donation page there
so there you go that was my in and out
double double animal style with whole
grilled onion and chopped chilies
uh and let's take it back to georgian
alvin guys that was amazing
i'm super hungry now i want to try all
of this
well we all got to cook today which is
great but we also got to have a deeper
understanding of hamburger history which
is important i think very important
huge huge yo
i'm so hyped to get everybody back
together for this episode
thank you so much until next time guys
thanks elena
burger show baby
[Music]
what's up burger world thank you for
watching make sure you hit that like
button
smash that subscribe button ring that
notification bell
if not for me for the burgers
i love you